la suite de l'actualité maintenant avec
qu'en france l'événement du jour
christine et jean marie villemin qui ont
décidé d'arrêter leur grève de la faim
la mère du petit grégory qui est
enceinte d'un autre enfant est en prison
depuis vendredi dernier elle avait
aussitôt entamé cette action pour
protester de son innocence son mari
l'avait suivi et c'est lundi prochain
que la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de nancy décidera si oui ou non
celle qui est inculpé aujourd'hui du
meurtre de son fils doit tous nous
demeurer en prison
sur place notre envoyé spécial marcel
rire et sylvie mas n'a pas voulu donner
aux magistrats de la cour d'appel de
nancy le sentiment désagréable qu'ils
allaient siéger sous la pression d'un
chantage
elle a donc annoncé depuis la prison de
metz l'arrêt de sa grève de la faim
sitôt connue la date de réunion de la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
qui doit statuer en dernier ressort sur
sa demande de mise en liberté provisoire
lundi matin 9h une date
exceptionnellement rapprocher si l'on
songe que les magistrats disposer de 30
jours pour prendre leur décision
la grève de la faim de christine
villemin aura donc été payante en
obligeant la machine judiciaire accéléré
le cours des choses en la prolongeant
elle risquait de perdre ce premier
avantage
christine villemin enceinte de cinq mois
et demi souffre on le sait de troubles
rénaux et circulatoires elle était
depuis cinq jours sous la surveillance
d'un gynécologue et d'un médecin
généraliste
prévenus par télégramme à la prison de
nancy jean marie villemin vient
d'annoncer à son tour l'arrêt de sa
grève de la faim ce qui achève de faire
retomber la tension
lundi matin à huis clos les magistrats
de nancy étudieront le rapport du juge
lambert opposé à la mise en liberté
provisoire
les réquisitions du procureur le compte
qui est favorable et la plaidoirie de
maître garot
nul ne peut préjuger de la décision
qu'ils prendront ce qui est sûr
maintenant c'est qu'ils pourront
trancher dans un climat de relative
sérénité